throughout history music has always been from the perspective of the artist writing the song they're usually about our lives our experiences but there are so many stories out there in the world that our way weirder wilder and more beautiful than anything the two of us could ever experience in our lifetime so we decided we wanted to create an EP about you guys the first EP entirely written from your life experiences and we're working with AT&T hello lab to make it happen all we need from you is to share your stories with us Instagram them tweet them if you want and tag them for us to find using our hashtag or you can send them through our website and check out all the submission rules there and we're gonna turn the most amazing stories into music it's called public record and it starts now we can't wait wait to write about